hey everyone what's up welcome back my
name is Ashe Crossan I'm here with Mike
Rochelle from GameSpot and today we're
gonna be talking about Thor Ragnarok and
giving her a little review a wacky fun
awesome super fun this is the third Thor
movie of course we've seen Thor a bunch
of times and other Avengers related
adventures but this one is very
different from the other Thor movies
that was super different and it feels
like it's all taiko Itt the director yes
he had a ton of influence over it and
it's totally his identity his
sensibilities and every part of the
movie that's great I feel like you can
attribute it directly to tell you it's
pure tech I have to say definitely watch
his other two movies before you see this
one especially hunt for the world er
people at least for me because there are
some kind of cameos and things in it
that you're like oh he has like frequent
collaborators especially from New
Zealand who he works with all the time
like Jeff Goldblum's characters sidekick
in in this movie with the whether they
call it the melt wand yeah it's so good
but but she's naturally she was in hunt
for the older people also tyka directed
and starred in what we do in the shadows
which is like this vampire like
flatmates comedy that's like it's so
good like they're vampires but their
problem is like who's gonna do the
dishes it's like it's like and that
that's the kind of situational comedy
that like really makes it into Thor
Ragnarok that was really a surprise for
me yeah definitely and tyka actually has
a role in the movie as Korg which isn't
a spoiler because you can't tell it's
him but Korg is really really like
probably one of my favorite new
characters not yeah well he does he does
the voice yeah and it's it's right away
I was like I was like that's either
Murray the the band manager from Flight
of the Conchords or let's take it
himself it's like it's that kind of like
soft-spoken like Kiwi accent just saying
kind of ridiculous non sequiturs
constantly mm-hmm but it's a totally
it's somehow it works for me i mean i
would compare thor ragnarok to like it's
like the bright colorful funny like it's
definitely kind of like a guardian slash
Doctor Strange kind of era so if you
like those movies you're 100% gonna like
it I'd put it like right under Doctor
Strange for me
mine's like guardians Doctor Strange
really
oh I definitely I liked it more than dr.
strange dr. strange had kind of that the
the trippy like acid trip imagery that I
really loved but for me definitely this
is more up there with guardians it's the
same it's colorful it's funny it's it's
like a comedy first and Thor has always
been kind of funny because like he's a
ridiculous character what else do you do
with that character he's he's the god of
thunder existing in this world with
mostly normal people Stark is just like
a rich guy so what do you do with him
besides you have to make it a little bit
tongue-in-cheek but this is like
multiple steps beyond that like it's
yeah really funny
I was wondering cuz a lot of people
after they saw it were saying it was
maybe too comedic did you think that no
because again I don't know what else you
can do with Thor to move it forward and
make it feel different because if you
take it too seriously it's like now
we're talking about gods and and the
underworld and other dimensions and it
the Marvel Universe to me is best when
it stays grounded even when we're
talking about like the cosmic stuff
guardians of galaxy like magic literally
with dr. strange but there's always
rules and having actual gods as
characters there's a danger of breaking
those rules so I think when you when you
tilt it instead toward comedy I think it
makes it work a lot better what am i one
of my favorite things about Wonder Woman
just pivoting to DC for sure it was when
she's in London and she's just so like
naive and doesn't know what's going on
doesn't know what basic things are
that's what I loved about yeah that's
what I love about Thor I do that I
totally agree like the beginning of
Wonder Woman when she's
when she's you know they're still doing
the origin story like that stuff was
almost cheesy to me and and what I loved
is when you insert her into the real
world and that's why people love when
when Thor goes to New York and there's a
brief spot the beginning of the movie
when Doctor Strange is in it and Thor
and Loki go to New York and and Thor is
wearing like a hoodie he seems very
nondescript and yeah and Loki looks like
what's the joke they make of it it looks
like he came from someone's funeral he's
like very guy he's just a tall black if
he's got a full black hand yeah I mean
it's it's a it's a good joke but also
it's like the fish-out-of-water thing
and it's funny yeah well they're up
against Caitlin
it's hella goddess of death and there's
been a lot of talk in the past about
Marvel having a villain problem so the
question is is hello hella got us a
death acred Marvel villain and I'm gonna
say not really yeah I'm gonna go hard no
hard no it's not it's not Cate Blanchett
Cate Blanchett is amazing for me it was
like every time they cut back to a
hellas story I was like oh my gosh just
get back to Thor get back to the other
part get back to the fun stuff because
it just felt like this weird B story
where I didn't really care what she was
doing it also it to me it makes no sense
like so she's Thor and Loki 's sister
and she has all this history with Odin
and this history with Asgard like
literally at one point there's like the
big there's this big set piece this big
mural of Odin benevolently ruling over
the people of Asgard and and at one
point she literally smashes it and
underneath is a different mural of Odin
and hella like ruling with an iron fist
and conquering all these realms and it's
like wouldn't we have heard about this
at some point so her and tire she just
feels shoehorned into the world in a way
that I felt wasn't believable and then
beyond that
all her motivation is is just is what is
just I was shut out and I should rule
the Iron Throne she's just mad she just
wants to conquer Asgard and be in charge
it's just it's it's a standard world
domination thing that's it's not
plausible and it doesn't really add much
it kind of felt like Marvel was like
okay we have a villain problem what
worked before for sibling why don't we
just happen my god Thor already has an
evil sibling yeah
and Loki is still doing like Trixie Loki
stuff it's not like it's not like Loki
and Thor against hella it's like Loki is
still doing the Loki thing and so now
Thor has like two evil siblings that he
has to deal with like who are good
Marvel villains in your opinion from
from past Marvel movies yes
Loki's the best Loki is the best I
didn't hate ego the Living Planet I
thought he was interesting yeah he was
definitely interesting
I mean Winter Soldier comes to mind
bucky yaki and Michael Keaton in
spider-man home come oh great yeah that
was right too because he because he
doesn't want to rule the world he just
wants to make money and provide his
family and say you relate to him
his motivations are realistic it's a
more personal story and this was none of
those things well there's a there's
another like side villain in this movie
Grandmaster played by Jeff Goldblum and
I would have almost like to see him as
just the villain through the whole movie
like I would have rather seen a movie
that's just him trying to get out of the
car I don't know if I would even call
him the villain because to me he was the
hero he was so great he was so great
he's so good I mean Jeff Goldblum liked
it it felt like it and this is another
part of the movie where you really see
Tycho's influence and his sensibilities
because it feels like and even watching
them together during like the the press
conference that they did it feels like
they just kind of ripped off each other
and and they talked a lot about the
improvisation that went on on on set and
Goldblum is so good at that he's got
he's been doing it for decades he's got
that shtick of like being kind of just
the crazy wacky non-sequitur guy and he
they just every scene he's in is like
you don't know what he's gonna say max
it's so it's so so funny it's so good I
loved him but they also introduced
another character we've got Valkyrie
played by Tessa Thompson who was going
to be everyone's women crush every day
after seeing oh my god I mean she just
was so like captivating every time I saw
her and I mean it's her cuz she loses a
lot yeah yeah she steals every scene
she's thinking about whether she's drunk
or sober yeah she has this power over
Thor both physically and and she seems
to have some kind of other power over
him and they seem to kind of set up like
a romance a little bit now I hope so too
but I I also like that it didn't fully
go there in this movie they just kind of
setup that there's a rapport between
them even as she's literally like she's
got this like remote taser thing
connected to him and she's just like
shocking him basically whatever she
feels like no III haven't wondered - if
if she's not in infinity war which is
like a rumor I don't know if that's
confirmed or not if they're gonna end up
putting her in or upping whatever role
she had kind of like healthcare doing
with like Wonder Woman in Justice League
because they're just like oh wait people
love this we have to
yeah well I think she's definitely gonna
be an important part of at the very
least the Thor corner of this universe
in the future without spoilers there are
some other characters within that world
that are not gonna be in it anymore so I
think that there's definitely room for
her there and I I would not object to
seeing just seeing Tessa Thompson
continue into infinity war and Beyond
there's so many people I want to see her
with like Rocket Raccoon right I think
he would like her yeah and that's that's
so much of the fun is that they've
established his is how these different
worlds crossover and seeing different
characters interact with each other I
mean I'm excited for for Thor to meet
the guardians in general and yeah having
having Valkyrie in the mix is definitely
I mean she was besides Jeff Goldblum she
was definitely my favorite addition to
this to this fiction yeah for me was
like overall loved the movie and my one
thing that I wish I could change was
just like hella I just I mean that's a
big part of it though everything about
it was so great that I can almost feel
like okay like I didn't like this part
but I would watch it over and over and
again just to see all the stuff in the
car and all that totally it's it's one
of the it's definitely on the the
spectrum of Marvel movies it is way
further toward greatness it's further
toward in my mind guardians which is my
favorite of all of these games one and
it has similar sensibilities and it has
a similar fun levity with the way that
it treats the source material and and
yeah I love it a lot and it's just too
bad that they can't get over this this
villain problem I know I know
I think that I think they'll bring take
it back for another well yeah Kevin
Feige said that he they're definitely
gonna work together again I mean if I
was Marvel I would be happy with this
and my takeaway if I was them would be
that you can get talented directors that
have unique you know idiosyncratic
sensibilities and you can allow them to
imprint themselves on these big
blockbuster movies and the results are
good James Gunn did it with guardians
he's like the DS the jumping-off point
exactly yeah
and it works it does we have to talk
about Karl Urban in this movie as well
as
George scourge Orchard Church scourge
that guy I'm very funny though I thought
he's like he was like overshadowed by
some of the other characters but I loved
him yeah I mean I think Karl Urban is
funny Anna I don't know if scourge was
funny in in my opinion I when he's
running to tell when he's like running
to announce Thor that was amazing that's
a good gag but that's like the first
five minutes and to me he spent the rest
of the movie kind of just off to the
side scowling at things that he'll was
doing mm-hmm I felt like he was under
you underused I can agree with that the
moments that he had were very good
mm-hmm he didn't have enough fun what
about Hemsworth loving embrace I mean
he's been so great in so many comedies
and we've seen him play this like
straight Thor and then in this one he's
just he's hilarious well he had funny
funny mo imeem one of my favorite
moments from the original four is when
he he Chuck's that coffee cup down he
says boy I love this badge yeah it's so
good and we're seeing that's the side of
Thor that they're really leaning on and
to me Hemsworth has that comic side that
we're finally getting to see him really
flex and at the same time he to me
embodies Thor just so perfectly he is
Thor to me I you know I had to say about
him there's a scene too with another
Avenger
that I loved their whole dynamic and I
loved everything that Thor was doing and
I think I know you're talking about yes
yeah is excellent but also I loved Hulk
in this movie because it was just a
different Bruce Banner because he had
these effects of being Hulk for so long
that he was just kind of like I'm not
like dumbed down but he was very on edge
at all times he was he was childlike and
it was interesting because every time I
feel I think every time we've seen the
Hulk in the MCU before when he is the
Hulk he's pretty much just rage mode and
he rarely talks even and this was
definitely the most dialogue as Hulk
that we've ever seen and it's a
different side of him I didn't
necessarily feel like it was explained
very well
other than the idea that he's been the
Hulk for a long time yeah when we pick
up with him in this movie and so maybe
he's gotten more used
he's able to express himself a little
better I've only I've only saw I've only
seen in interviews when they're like
well when he's hauled for so long and he
goes back the effects are Krita they
didn't explain it as well in the movie
but I mean in context though it does
work very well and and it's a chore
because there's so much of him they had
to you know you have to have him talk
and and I mean there's a scene between
him and Hemsworth that they're just it's
that type of humor but they're just
sitting on the edge of the bed yeah just
having an argument it feels like a very
intimate like personal moment between
these two characters and it's the kind
of thing that we don't always get to see
we get to see them in these movies when
these movies are at their best so I love
that scene and I'm excited to see where
the Hulk goes next I'm so excited to see
this movie again and I think this goes
without saying because it's a Marvel
movie but stay for the credits right do
you have theories about that uh stinger
that that's it that's C I will say it's
very ambiguous like it's right full
disclosure
nobody we've spoken with actually knows
what the what the credits tag is yes so
when you see it you can let us know your
thoughts because I'm sure there's
somebody watching that like it's so
steeped in the comics that they will
write it's probably a reference to
something that happened in some obscure
line from the 70s for all we know
because everybody I've spoken with has
just been like well we have theories but
yeah no one can connect it to anything
concrete but yeah I mean we'll probably
know once
infinity war hits but yeah so yeah
that's that so if you've if you see it
and you know just let us know and that's
all we'll say about that because I don't
want to give anything away cuz I don't
need I don't need that today well I
guess we'll leave it there overall
review the overall takeaway I mean it's
it's a definite it's a definite yes
definite yes yeah it's with some
reservations but it's just that one
thing oh yeah but other than that I
absolutely love it so yeah go see it and
then let us know your thoughts because
our twitter handles will be right here
below this is my stick i do this every
time
cool
our Twitter handles will be here I do
the brain stick yeah do different thing
they're here so if you like this video
like comment subscribe let us know your
thoughts on Twitter and I will see you
guys next time thanks so much for
joining thank you for having me
bye guys